hallo ihr lieben heute machen wir einen
noblen ich weiß nicht ob man den kuchen
oder torten nennen kann
denn er besteht aus butterkeksen und
pudding und der ist unglaublich lecker
glaubt ihr werdet ihn lieben vor allem
alle schoko fans ich liebe ihn auch und
gerade weil so warmem wetter wie heute
und auch gerne mal in mitte wenn einfach
mal vor seiten keine lust habt ist das
die perfekte alternative
jetzt zeige ich euch zu aller erst mal
die zutaten wir benötigen ganz einfache
butterkekse und außerdem werden wir
jetzt ein schoko pudding kochen
dafür benötigen wir seine kuvertüre
speisestärke ba kakao und zucker und wir
starten jetzt auch zuallererst mit dem
leckeren schoko pudding und der ist
total schokoladig weil wir am erstens
unseren bacau drinne der sorgt sowieso
schon für die schokoladige note jesus
wichtig dass ihr kein trick cacau nimmt
sondern wirklich den stark enthüllten
bacau und zweiter ist was das ganze noch
schokoladiger macht ist unsere kuvertüre
ich habe jetzt sagt peter genommen ihr
könnt auch voll mich nehme ich ganz euch
überlassen funktioniert mit beidem
und wir machen mir zuallererst folgendes
wir geben speisestärke und bei kakao und
eine separate schüssel und verrühren das
mit der hälfte der milch oder ungefähr
ein drittel reicht auch ob serie
verrührt das glatt
[Musik]
so die masse ist jetzt komplett
klümpchen verrückt manchmal geht das ein
bisschen schwieriger weil er der kakao
fettarmes und dadurch so trocken ist
aber sieht so dass keine türmchen mehr
drin sind und dann machen wir weiter ich
merke dass mein top riesig ist haben sie
gestern war den kleineren topf bitte
muss ich nicht nur ja da muss ich nicht
soviel spülen brenner das geht schneller
dankeschön so und jetzt geben wir die
restliche milch zusammen mit der
ouvertüre und dem zucker in den topf
jetzt habe ich den herd eingeschaltet
auf mittlerer stufe unter ständigem
rühren wir das jetzt einmal aufgelöst
sodass eben schokolade sich auflöst und
die zuckerkristalle auch so jetzt ist
die schokolade geschmolzen und das
riecht schon richtig gut und es sieht
auch schon richtig gut aus jetzt kommt
der rest dazu
und danach wird das ein mal aufgekocht
tut mir eingefallen bitte bitte nehmt
keine fertigte das schmidt so total
lecker die zutaten hat man ja eigentlich
immer zu hause
ich hab das jetzt unter ständigem rühren
einmal aufkochen lassen hier seht ihr
die bläschen und das ganze ist auch
eingedeckt und wir haben einen richtig
schönen leckeren schoko pudding erhalten
jetzt nämlich das ganze vom herd und wir
gehen darüber an unsere vormund zudem
butterkeksen so jetzt habe ich mich hier
mein tablett bereit gelegt
beziehungsweise irgendein teller wo er
das ganze drauf serien möchtet dann habe
ich noch einen eckigen backen darüber
gelegt und jetzt nehmen uns die
butterkekse und geben die erst mal
komplett auf den boden hier habe ich
auch noch mal ein schokopudding und
damit sich oben keine haut bildet gehe
ich alle paar sekunden menowin einmal
durch und dann kann ich hier
weitermachen
wichtig ist dass sie mit in butter
keksen auf dem boden startet und jetzt
gibt dir ein teil des des schoko pudding
es darüber und wie viel ihr nehmt ist
vollkommen euch überlassen
wollt ihr mehr butterkeks anteil oder
lieber mehr schoko es vollkommen euch
überlassen einfach je nach augenmaß ein
bisschen drüber geben und glatt
streichen
[Musik]
und das prinzip ist so einfach einfach
immer alles nacheinander schichten und
irgendwann seid ihr dann fertig habt
alles aufgebraucht und dann könnt ihr
das ganze nur noch dekoriert und warten
bis es auskühlt
[Musik]
und das ist so ein kuchen den mac
einfach jeder also hand aufs herz wer
mag so eine kombination nicht ich weiß
es ist ein bisschen mogelei dabei dafür
braucht euch doch gar nicht schämen das
ist manchmal ist es einfach einfach ist
manchmal so gut und deshalb bereitet
jedoch gerne mal zu überrascht war über
familie und dann werdet ihr sehen wie
erstaunt sie sind dass sowas einfach ist
so lecker schmecken kann wo die
einfachen kuchen geschrieben höhere
bisher sind ja auch die einfachen dinge
sind manchmal die leckersten
jetzt habe ich das ganze fertig
geschichte insgesamt drei schichten
butterkekse drei schichten schokopudding
so finde ich es perfekt dann könnt ihr
ganz einfach schauen wie ihr das mögt
und damit jetzt der kunde keine haut
bildet oder ich persönlich mag das
einfach nicht es gibt tatsächlich leute
die mögen das macht ihr da schreibt man
gern einen kommentar war es um mein gott
bist du warst du mit haben sie gemacht
aber eben angeblich da jetzt noch was
drüber damit ich diese haut ihm später
nicht habe ich nehme jetzt in dem fall
diese schoko später hier ihr könnt auch
kokos nehmen oder nüsse vollkommen euch
überlassen
[Musik]
und das gute stück hier kommt jetzt für
mindestens zwei stunden in den
kühlschrank damit es auch schon fest
wird nichts verrutscht während des
abschnitts und genau dann sehen wir uns
wieder
ihr könnt übrigens die frage kommt ganz
oft das am vortag vorbereitet ist auch
kein problem dann einfach über nacht in
den kühlschrank stellen
natürlich sehr gerne so die kühl zeit
ist um ein programm habe ich entfernt
und jetzt werde ich den kuchen nur noch
dekorieren mit auf geschlagener sahne
die habe ich umgesetzt denn der kuchen
ist denke ich mal süß genug und da habe
ich jetzt eine rosen tolle vorne dran
und da spritzt sich jetzt einfach kleine
rosen drauf und dann teilen wir das ja
dadurch ein dann sieht man wo man das
ganze entlang schneiden kann
[Musik]
so die sahne tupfen sind jetzt oben
drauf und jetzt gebe ich noch so schoko
späne darüber und dann ist es eigentlich
auch schon fertig dekoriert
natürlich könnt ihr alles mögliche
nehmen ich habe zum beispiel auch diese
mini kekse genommen ihr könntet jetzt
auch rein tun als alles was euch so
einfällt wenn markus schug spiel ist ach
so das war ganz einfach ich hab hier
einfach hier den diesen blog von meiner
kuvertüre genommen und dann einfach das
messer hier so angesetzt und dann drüber
gezogen
der vorfall hat das jetzt hier
rübergezogen dann erhaltet ihr halt so
ganz dünne suppe die sie zuletzt auch
nie aus
[Musik]
sollen jetzt probiere ich mal für euch
möchte ich aber auch gerne mal zeigen
wie weit er ist so ich weiß ja ob man
zieht es oft und so weich und ich habe
denen damals in meiner schwester immer
gerne gemacht in so einer runden
auflaufform weil er ist kinderleicht den
kann einfach jeder machen und die
geschmäcker entwickeln sich zwar aber
das hier das mag ich nach wie vor also
das mag ich immer noch total gern auch
wenn ich schon fast 26 bin soll jetzt
wieder normal gegessen
lecker war so sein dass mit total lecker
ich finde das deutsche gesetz gemacht
ist sowieso immer ein bisschen besser
schmeckt damals als kind habe ich sie
nur bücher genommen
ich möchte ein bisschen künstlich
deswegen macht ihn lieber selber tut
schön schokolade mit rein wunderbar
perfekt so fast das ganze nachmachen
möchte schaut man unten in die infobox
verstehen alle genauen mengenangaben und
auch die größe der form dieses variablen
da könnte auch paar zentimeter größer
oder kleiner ist auch kein problem
ansonsten freue ich mich wenn ihr meinen
kanal abonniert mir ein bisschen da oben
da lässt und dann sehen wir uns am
nächsten mal wiederkommen
ich glaub ich mache gar nicht so ich
glaube ich mache natürlich mach dir mal
freue mich darauf
abonniert mal schön auf instagram damit
ihr das noch nicht verpasst haben sollte
das ist ein versprechen vor kamera muss
es durchziehen
hansa mixed a club mehr spielen muss
kaum eine runde kommt eine runde eins
ein punkt kommt weiter schnick schnack
schnuck erstmals ist man doch gar nicht
so
wir haben jetzt abends zurück und wir
können uns selbst ein stück kuchen und
die uhrzeit unser zweites stück euch ja
schon zitronen bis die volle gegessen
kommt übrigens auch bei den über heute
für euch gemacht aber nicht gebacken des
novo die geschmacksprobe beginnt wartet
du musst den bildern wieder okay